- [Evan] "When your
values are clear to you,
"making decisions becomes easier."
Roy E. Disney.
Making decisions can be hard
when you don't know what you stand for.
Your one word is your core.
It's your guided light.
It makes all decisions easier.
If you don't have that guiding light,
then you never completely feel
like you're going in the right direction.
You'll constantly second guess yourself,
not being sure if you
made the best choice.
You'll spend more time agonizing
over decisions and acts
than making the decision
to improve your life
and the life of others.
When you know your one word,
you can make decisions
that support your path.
Decisions that were difficult before
now become easy to make.
You know if you should
start that business or not.
move to that city or not.
You know if you should
marry that person or not.
It's also easy for people to understand
who you are and how they can help you.
Everything becomes easier,
your life, your business.
Everything becomes much easier.